in the last video we talked about a
general scheme about what goes on with
eukaryotic transcription in terms of
enhancer involvement here I want to talk
about cyclic AMP II as a specific
regulator of gene expression so we
imagine this DNA strand here with the
Tata box and star site here at the
promoter and RNA polymerase is tues
basal complex preparing to bind that
promoter now to be clear I want to
mention that this basal complex of
course includes the RNA polymerase 2 and
then any basal transcription factors
associated with it just for the sake of
simplicity I'm not going to go in and
draw all those transcription factors so
now this enhancer over here is labeled
as cre now CRE is a specific enhancer it
stands for cyclic GMP response element
so that cyclic GMP response element is a
specific enhancer now initially this RNA
polymerase won't bind very effectively
to the promoter so it needs to be
enhanced so if it won't bind the
promoter effectively that means no
transcription so if this
cific transcription factor here CREB
binds the enhancer then maybe we can get
transcription to go so CR e b stands for
cre binding protein so it binds to the
cyclicamp response element okay so this
C Rab is a specific transcription factor
and it binds the cre the cyclic AMP II
response element which is the specific
enhancer now when there's an increase in
cyclic A&P in the cell SIV again P
activates out of this little green plus
sign here represents it activates cyclic
GMP dependent protein kinases
specifically protein kinase a now these
protein kinases they add phosphates to
proteins so this protein kinase a when
it's active it's going to phosphorylate
CR a B and when that happens we get the
DNA to loop around as we have seen
before now once it loops around the creb
now has a phosphate group attached to it
and that C Rab is bound to the cyclic or
the cyclic AMP e response element which
is the specific enhancer now this brown
portion here represents the basal
complexes at the promoter now there is
this protein in between the creb and the
RNA polymerase complex that is CBP CBP
that stands for creb binding protein and
what it is is it's a co-activator
or otherwise known as a mediator so what
happens here is it mediates the response
it sort of connects the enhancer to the
promoter in a sense of via these protein
protein interactions then when that
happens it allows the RNA polymerase to
bind and bind effectively and then we
have transcription this is of course
enhanced because initially it couldn't
bind effectively
okay so now this basically all happened
because this sip of gay MP increase if
the super gay MP increase did not
officially increase did not happen then
CRE V wouldn't have this phosphate group
attached to it and the transcription
wouldn't have been enhanced but where
did this cyclic AAP come from well it
probably came from because of an extra
cellular signal so we talked about how
you know certain cases and we had
g-protein coupled receptors that
increase the concentration of cyclic GMP
through adenylate cyclase that increased
cyclic AMP II was because of some
hormone binding event so if this
extracellular signal called caused an
increase in cyclic a and P this is how
an extra cellular signal can cause you
know a change in transcription this just
affected transcription so certain extra
cellular signals trigger their responses
by altering transcription so that's
pretty gnarly I think I hope that video
was helpful one last thing I am a tutor
if you live in Southern California feel
free to contact me via email at move
University at gmail.com see the
description below for more details thank
you for watching